bonjour alors comme beaucoup de gens
j'ai testé cette fameuse application de
rencontre et ça y est j'ai enfin trouvé
l'amour
voilà vous connaissez anthisnes d'heure
à peine adopte un mec assez plus ou
moins toujours le même principe c'est
pour flirter rencontrer l'amour voir
pratiquer le sexe ou directement
pratiquer le sexe avant dans ma tête les
gens qu utiliser ce genre d'applications
c'était plutôt des gens comme ça n'ayant
pas trouvé l'amour dans les agences
matrimoniales
je tente ma chance sur terre un sticker
à peine vivant chez ma mère à l'âge de
43 ans
je ne vous cache pas que j'aimerais bien
me des puces et les i mais en fait ça
c'est carrément démocratiser sur d'appli
maintenant latitude peut trouver plein
de petites meufs frêche est mignonne
l'inde beau gosse style et musclé viril
pardon alors au début chez les patrons
quelles applications utilisées alors
j'ai tout télécharger pour voir sauf que
maintenant quand les gens regardent mon
portable
ils me prennent pour un bon gros tas le
l'homme au chien avec apple la
particularité c'est que tu peux parler
avec des gens que tu as vraiment croisé
dans la vie ce qui est plutôt pratique
jamais regard qui m'a fermé sur la pomme
a pu tant il est trop mal je m'étais
amusé je ferai de mon mieux j'ai tout
entendu là une fois je discute avec une
fille j'ai demandé un ça va
et je vous jure avoir répondu vous êtes
actuellement réduit à l'état de sous
merde je sais parfois vu des profils de
meuf avait dit clients biographie je
recherche uniquement des amis étaient
sérieuses là tu cherches des amis mais
c'est pas sûr tender stands et inscrire
un
c'est une colonie de vacances c'est quoi
ces gens qui ne comprennent pas le
principe d'une api de rencontre mais
voilà moi je me suis inscrite sur tinner
ont des fonds pour faire des amis es toi
moi c'est pour avoir ma carte hier la
très peu servi alors mon état je la fais
à 15 heures au studio je rappelais sur
le bon coin mais je suis un peu con un
petit bijou souvent sur ce genre d'appli
tu peux voir star d'intérêt commun avec
les gens ce qui est plutôt pratique pour
engager une discussion mais ce qui est
trop nul c'est que parfois ton seul
intérêt commun avec la meuf
ah bah il est carrément moyens alors
comme ça toi aussi tu es là qu'est la
page facebook télé loisirs
je comprends pas les meufs qui va des
photos d'elle à plusieurs genres elles
sont à 3 sur la photo tu sais pas
laquelle c'est ça n'a aucun sens à moins
qu'elles cherchent un plan à plusieurs
attend que c'était quoi le profil de jeu
j'ai une amie qui m'a montré son compte
apple et j'ai bien vu que sur un aspect
de rencontre le compte d'un mec et d'une
meuf c'est vraiment pas la même chose
le compte d'un mec le compte d'une meuf
le compte d'un mec parfois au salut
salut rejoindra w pour un max de sexe ok
je viens vite fait alors parce qu'en
fait mon la page bon peut pas vraiment
dire vu que j'ai mis mes photos et mon
nom et tout est pas mal de meuf qui
m'ont reconnue par rapport à mes vidéos
ouais je suis hyper connus et ouais le
mec a le melon ouais je me suis fait
reconnaître qu est-ce qu il ya j'adore
saint-trop' alors on pourrait se dire
que c'est un point qui est vraiment
positif mais pas forcément en fait je
suis sûr que tu es un fake bah non je te
jure je suis vraiment normal envoie sa
fille pour voir mouais ça pourrait très
bien être un seul film norman quitte à
récupérer sur internet si c'est vraiment
toi prends toi en photo avec une lampe
dans la main gauche une banane dans la
main droite
si ça se trouve le vrai normale avait
fait la même fait une vidéo de toi ou tu
dit elodie salue le dit ben voilà c'est
normal façon je te crois pas tant je
t'ai pas vu en vrai
ouais tu pourrais très bien lui
ressembler beaucoup je te jure c'est
normal regarde c'est écrit sur ma carte
d'identité
ah ouais ouais je te crois voilà enfin à
baron je suis pas du tout intéressé 1
c'était juste par curiosité même journée
sous sous merde
vu que j'en avais un peu marre que les
filles crois que tu as un fake un jour
j'ai mis sur mon profil je vous rassure
je suis bel et bien le vrai et puis j'ai
reçu ce genre de message pourquoi tu
écris je suis le brice ton profil je te
connais pas tu es qui t'as l'air
d'ailleurs trop le melon bressan sur
terre ces personnes pour moi au caire
sous sous sous merdes façon faut bien
jouer ce genre de rencontre par
application c'est pas forcément très
romantique
qu'est ce que tu as raconté plus tard à
tes enfants papa comment tu as rencontré
maman ne mangera cours de votre mère je
me rappelle comme si c'était hier
j'étais en train de dérouler un cake
tout en appelant les meufs sur tender
quand soudain j'ai vu votre mère quel
sourire quel regard j'ai poussé très
fort on est là j'ai mis un super like et
quand je suis sorti des toilettes les
enfants j'étais à la fois soulagé d
constipé est amoureux pour la séduire je
pense que je me laisser pousser la
moustache
merci tinner
alors je vous rassure ce n'est pas une
pub cacher pour les applis de rencontre
mais juste le triste état actuel de ma
vie sentimentale ou deux mais quand un
chien
je comprends que des gens qui peuvent
trouver l'amour dessus mais c'est pas
trop mon truc je pense que rien ne
remplacera jamais une rencontre dans la
vraie vie autour d'une soirée d'un
hasard d'une discussion d'un monopoly
du coup je vous laisse j'ai un peu
profiter de la vraie vie et je vous
rappelle que ce soit sur apple tender
adopte un mec ou autres sortez couverts
je vous souhaite plein de bonnes choses
parce que je vous aime tous beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup et si vous
avez apprécié ma vidéo mettez un pouce
en l'air pour l'amour du loft
fabrice très simple c'est papa cigognes
qui va dans le nid de maman cigognes et
là il commence un petit peu à faire des
bisous ah bon [ __ ] j'étais persuadé
que ça se passait comme dans la
catégorie gang bang sur xhamster away